だから答え出します これからは
社会から別にブッダから学ばなくてメインです
社会から学んでみましょうと
人間は二人か二人以上一緒に生活すると
そちらに社会という現象が成り立つ
これからはもうこんなもうお経文句みたいに全部覚えて覚えるしかないんです
これ定義が必要なんで
社会っていうのは人間二人がいると社会なんです
大げさに考えないでください
人間二人だったらもう社会です
この社会関係がうまくいっていると言えるのはどんな時でしょうかという
あまりレトリック書きたくないんだけど
もうレトリックで書くしか方法ないんですね
日本語的にはすごいみんなレトリックばっかしでね
だってもう中間的で何も言ってないでしょうに
言ってるようで何も言ってない世界だからね
まあだいたい英語で書く場合はすごく嫌がるんです
レトリックっていうのはね
どんな時でしょうかとかね
どうでもいいんだから
考えなくても とにかくこの場合はこれで書くしか方法ないんです
どんな時でしょうかと
これから考えましょうと
これレトリックじゃないんです
その条件を具体的にリストアップしてみると
世間知らずの問題に解決方法を見出せる
これからちゃんとリストアップしてみましょう
どういうことかというと
人間関係がうまくいっているケース
社会から見てリストアップするんです
それリストアップの中で
これたくさんありますよ
仏教の場合はこのたくさんのは面倒くさいんだから
もうぎゅっと基本的な柱だけに縮めるんです
第一 役に立つということ
皆さんは宿題でリストアップした方がいいんで
皆さんも知ってる人々いるでしょうに
人間関係うまくいってる人々とかね
いるんだったら その人はなんでうまくいってるのかとリストアップしてみてください
結構見つかりますよ その中でこちらでいくつかのポイントだけ
いくつかとも最初から言わない
まあどうせやりますからね
いくつかのポイントだけ言います
一番は役に立つということ
自分が役に立つか 相手が役に立つかは条件 第一です
相手が自分に役に立つかですね
自分が相手の役に 相手が自分の役に立つかということは条件第一なんです
役に立つと そちらには人間関係できてます
だって赤ちゃんとお母さんの関係は全然問題ないでしょ
なぜかというと 赤ちゃんにしてみれば
もうお母さんというのはもうもう完璧に役に立つんだから
まあ言うことを聞く まあ問題はないんです
お母さんの周りでも まあもうちょっと遊べるようになってきたら
もう遊ぶはもう何でもやる
全然人間関係では問題はないんです
1歳になっても  2歳になっても
だから自分が役に立つか
相手が自分の役に立つかというどちらかなんです
例えば皆様は犬と猫の場合は人間関係の問題ないでしょ
まあたまにあるんだけど
まあ性格悪い人間の場合
大体はうまくいってますよ
犬猫飼っちゃえば なぜかというと
まあそこら辺で犬猫が可愛くて遊ぶ場合は自分が楽しいんだから自分の役に立ってるし
猫にしたっても犬にしたっても
この人は餌をくれるんだから
やっぱり役に立ってるでしょ
それで問題ない社会関係はできているんです
これが一方的なら 社会関係がたちまち壊れます
一方的っていうのは 私が役に立つんであって
相手からは私に何の役にも立たない
あるいは自分が相手からいろいろやってもらうんですが
自分が何もしてあげない
自分が役に立たない その場合の社会関係はすぐ壊れます
一人一人が自分がどのように相手の役に立つかを発見することですよ
答えは だから私たち一人一人
自分がどのように相手の役に立つのかということを発見してください
内向性外向性関係ないんですよ
あんなの間違ってますからね
あの心理学も全部 だからすごいシンプルで
私って本当に人の役に立つ
それだけなんですよ 役に立たないゴミだったら
もうこれからでも役に立つようにしてください
もう最低お守りにでもなってあげるぞとか
漬物の何でもいいんですよ
だって体があまり動かないね
まあ車椅子とかなんとかでも
それなりにおじいさんおばあさんでも
まあ家に留守番頼んで若者が遊びに行ったりするでしょ
それでおばあさんがもう私はもう腰が痛いんだからね
もうあまり歩けませんだからもういいや
いやと ディズニーランドなんかはこりごりやと
君たち行ってくださいと
それでおばあさんが家を守ってくれるでしょうに
どれほど役に立つかわかってますかね
それが あの膝がもうもうリウマチで動かない
もうもう杖であっちこっちちょこちょこと歩いているおばあさまが
家族にどれほど役に立つかと
だから別にそんな大したことじゃないんです
だからそのおかげで子供たちと娘か息子が
もう子供たちそれで平気で遊びに行くんだから
それで帰ってくると何か食べるものを作ってあるでしょう
まあそういうことで もうどうしても役に立つ
自分でどのように役に立つのかと
まあ発見してください
あの漬物の重りになってくれるんです
言ったっても あんまり役に立たないと思いますよ
石の方がいいんで その場合は
で それには内向 外向 中間は障害です
内向性 外向性 中間性っていうのは
社会関係を築くためには障害なんです
ものすごい障害です  第1条件は役に立つというそれだけなんです
で 役に立つのをちょっときめ細かい説明に入ります
1 社会を選ぶということ
皆様あんまりもうもう考えたことがないんだと思いますよ
こういう内容っていうのはね
だからまあしっかり聞いた方がいいんです
仏教的な見方っていうのは
軽々く見ているだけでね
本なんかにはないんです
自分が役に立つ場合 社会は自分を見放さないんですね
それは別に言わなくてもね
自分が役に立ってるんだったら
社会は自分を決して見放すことはしません
今の社会で生活したいなら
今の社会に役に立つように
と能力を開発する これがちょっと注釈しないとわからない文章なんですよ
今の社会というのは今自分の社会なんです
二人がいれば社会だからね
例えば今の自分の家族
今 例えば友達と一緒に生活しているならば
その一人二人がその社会なんですよ
あ それでよかったと思うならば
この家族でよかったと
この会社で良いと この友達と一緒に生活するのはそれでいいんだと思うならば
それが今の社会なんです
だったらそれだけでうまくいくわけじゃないんです
この社会に役に立つようにと何か自分が能力を能力を開発しなくちゃいけないんです
例えば 今まで家族の中でトラブルばっかりで喧嘩ばっかりでしたとする
しかし 自分がその家族でいいと思っている
だったら喧嘩することではなくて
トラブルを起こすことではなくて
どうすればこの家族に自分が役に立つのかとしてみれば
そこで幸せな家族が社会関係が築くんですよ
今の生活環境が変わっても良いと思われるなら
自分の能力を生かせる必要とする相手を選ぶ
これまた難しいポイントですよ
具体的な例で言えばわかりますよ
私は別に日本で一生生活しなくてもいいんじゃないかなと思っている場合は
別に日本の社会で一生過ごさってもそんな面白くないんだよと
それよりはカリフォルニアに住んだ方がいいんだよと
言うならば これ社会変えたいでしょ
本人が アメリカ 日本からアメリカに定住したいという気持ちでしょうね
別にいいんです それで社会変えたいと
でもアメリカカリフォルニアで住みたい
住みたいんだけど もうろくにもうグッドモーニングしか言えないならばね
グッドモーニングと言ったっても
もう言ってる本人しか誰もわからないでしょうね
プリーズホットコーヒーちょうだいと言ったっても
誰もわからないでしょうね
だってアメリカではホットコーヒーという言葉がないんだから
だから その社会に生きているためには
その能力を開発しなくちゃいけないんです
アメリカに行ってはいけないという意味じゃないんです
今結婚している人とその会社が
その社会がむちゃくちゃで
だったら これは離婚して辞めてもいいんですよ
辞めて自分が別な社会作るでしょうに
その別な社会に適応できるように
自分の能力をね 貢献できる能力を開発しなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから この役に立つか立たないかということが大事なことで
本当は自分にはすごく能力あるんだけど
役に立つはずなんですけど
このグループの役に立ちませんのと
まあいい例だって 例えばうちの息子は書道が上手やと
これがなんと言おうとも
大体 5メートル  10メートルの長さの紙で書くんだよと
でも 自分の小さなアパートで10メートルの紙をね
広げて書道を書くということは成り立たないんですよ
成り立たないでしょ かえって家に迷惑でしょうに
子供に能力があることは確かに能力あるんですよ
そこでも書いても書いても誰もお金払ってくれませんし
迷惑なんですよ 結局は
だからその家族にとっては
自分の息子の能力は迷惑なんですよ
それにその子供はこう考えればいいんです
自分が書道家で 普通の日本の書道家みたいにちょこっとした紙で書いているわけじゃないんです
かなり大胆なもので書いている
だったらこれ生かしてくれる社会じゃないのかと
例えばいろんな公の場所であらもう壁やら
そういうところで あの役所からお金もらって
ド派手に書道でもう 4メートルぐらい長さで何か書いてあげるとか
ビルの壁いっぱい上から下まで書道で何か書いてあげるとかね
そうやって自分の能力を生かすと生かせるところに行っちゃえば幸せでしょうに
そうするとあのアパートのお母さんも困らないで済むでしょうね
息子は全然家に帰ってこない
でもそれでいいと もうテレビ見ておせんべい食べながらお母さん一人でいられますからね
こいつは家で書道を書こうと思っちゃうと
もう何もできなくなっちゃいますから
台所まで使いますからね
だから自分の能力を生かせる社会を選ぶということなんです
必要とする相手を選ぶ
それで能力開発をし 同じことの2
これ大胆なことではありませんよ
社会の役に立つということは大胆なことではありません
そんな能力開発なんか言ったってもできるわけないんだそうと
もうとっくに暗くなってると思いますけどね
大胆なことじゃないんです
自分の社会の役に立つようにすることだけですので
難しくありませんよ 例えば二人で
もう家賃が高いんだから
二人で部屋を借りて生活している
それで社会でしょう とお互いに役に立つようにすることだけだから
それってそんなに難しいんですかね
例えば新妻なら料理を学ぶとかね
どうせそんなことやるでしょうね
そんなもんですよ 人生っていうのは
スケールを徐々に大きくする
まあ料理を新妻だったら料理をできるようになったら
もうちょこっと何かやろうではないかとかね
花婿それから勉強するとかね
そうやって徐々にスケール増えればいいんです
最初はもう何か役に立てばいいんですよ
徐々にスケール増えて
この人のの役に立つところから
例えば女の子だったら結婚した相手に
あ この人の役に立つようにするぞと思うでしょ
まあそれでいいんですよ
スタートはね でも死ぬまでこの人だけの役に立つっていうことはね
ちょっとつまらないんだからね
そこから自分のスケールを広げて広げていけばいいんですよ
死ぬまでお父さんの料理を作ることしかできませんよと言うと
ちょっとつまらないでしょうに
で ここから始めて 家族の役に立つ
周りの人々の役に立つ
地域の役に立つ 国の役に立つ
人類の役に立つとかね
そう広げてみてください
まあどこかでもう年取って死にますから
まあ人類の役に立つまではいかないかもしれませんだけど
とにかく死ぬまで自分の能力を広げていけば
役に立つ範囲を広げていけば
それこそ生き方でしょうに
何か文句でもありますかね
これ それが生き方なんですよ
それで次に役に立つは損するかと
一方的な役に立つは社会関係ではありません
一方的に役に立つ 奥さんが必死で旦那には尽くすんだけど
旦那が 何の役にも立てないと
もうこれで夫婦関係も何もないんだからね
旦那はもうお金さえも持ってこないんだったらね
それでもバカな女の人がいるんですよ
もうただ男は家にいるだけ
もう料理作ってきたっても
これはまずいとか文句まで言う
あれって女の人結構病気なんですよ
それでももう若い時とかね
若い時じゃなくて ちょこっと若さが終わったらやるんですよ
それで誰の男捕まえて家に泊まってもらって
もうやりもうお金であげて
料理作ってあげて 全然仕事もしない
パチンコだけやっていて
自分が苦労して仕事をするとね
あんなのはもうおかしいのにところで
やがて殺されますから
パチンコにお金くれ お金くれと言うんだから
料理はしないどころか
もう食べる もう女の人が仕事に行ってるんだからね
本人が食べた もう皿さえも洗うことしないと
そんなのはもうすぐたちまち恋関係切るべきなんですよ
いくらなんでも  それでももうやってる人々もいる
だから一方的な役に立つっていうのは人間関係じゃありません
自分にも役に立つから
相手の役に立つようにするのは俗世間で普通ですよ
だから私の役に立つんだから
私もその人の役に立つようにする
皆様方は給料をもらってるんだから
会社に行ってるでしょうに
だから給料欲しくて行ってるでしょうに
だから収入が役に立ってるんだから
タダで収入くれませんから
自分も会社に役に立つようにする
それってのは普通の常識ですよ
しかし 一方的に役に立つ人間でも
その行為によって優れた人格者になるはずです
それは総合型よりもすごいんです
一方的に役に立つ 自分が人の人々のことをいろんなことをやってあげてはいるんだけど
相手側からは何も見返りはありません
その場合 一方的でしょうね
しかし それも悪くないんですよ
人助けだから 見返りも期待しないで人助け
それはだから総合型と違いますけど
それはすごいんですよ
そんな人間っていうのは珍しいんだから
だから一方的に役に立つことも損するんじゃないんです
役に立つという一言葉は決して損する道ではありません
私はこき使われ こき使われているだけではないかとかね
そう思わなくてもいいんですよ
自分がそうこき使われてあっても
自分がまあもうあんなには役に立っているようにしているんだから
自分の人格は向上します
そこで 2番目 社会とうまくいっているケースのリストアップすると
2番目に項目になってくるのは身なりなんです
表面的な演奏もこの愚かな社会で大事なことです
これ馬鹿にならないんですよ
身なりは 見た目より中身だという人さえも
結局は中身より見た目に惹かれるんですよ
みんな偉そうなこと言うでしょ
見た目より中身だよと
実際は逆なんですけど
みんな中身どうでもいいんだけど
見た目に惹かれるんです
だから人間そんなもんだから
その現象を無視してはならない
偉そうに人間変えようと思っても変えるわけないでしょうに
だから身なりも気にするんです
だから人間関係がうまくいっている場合はよく調べてください
身なりがいいんですよ
ブッダも身だしなみを厳しく推薦するんです
仏教でも しかし 出家の場合
おしゃれ 化粧などは禁止
在家の場合はそんなこと言ってないんですけど
出家の場合は身だしなみは必要ですけど
おしゃれとか化粧とか
それは禁止 これどういうことかというと
インドではこのある結構非暴力主義は徹底した
虫 1匹も殺せない宗教があったんですよ
ヒンドゥー教は戦争する宗教だから
ヒンドゥー教ではありません
ジャイナ教なんです 牛は立派ですよ
虫 1匹も殺すなかれと
生水飲むなかれと 生水には命があるんだからと
そこまで厳しいんですけど
服は着ないんですよ あの...修行者たちは
それから体洗わないんですよ
生水に命があるんだだから洗えるわけないでしょ
それで体洗ったっていうことは
体に住み着いているいろんな生命を落とすことだから
殺生したことになるんですよ
だから体洗わないんです
髪の毛はもう一応剃ってますから
それは問題はないんです
考えてください 十年も体が洗ってない
また裸でいる聖者はもうすごい立派なことを教えてはいるんだけど
なんか聞きたい気持ちになるんですかね
近寄るとなんか鼻にきついでしょう
だからその方は本当は見た目ではなくて中身はいいんですよ
中身はいいのはわかってるんだけど
見た目はあれだから なかなか近寄れなくなっちゃうんです
だから身なりは必要なんです
いくら自分が役に立つ能力を持っていても
身なりがダメなら誰も近寄ってはこないんですし
もうお願いすることもしません
ですから 仏教では身なりっていうのはいろいろありますので
全部厳しいんです 次に 3番目
行儀作法 社会関係がうまくいっているということは
だいたい行儀作法もあります
これは相手とコミュニケーションを取る手段なので
決して無視してはならない
この行儀作法っていうのは
相手とのコミュニケーションなんですよ
コミュニケーションしなかったら社会関係ないでしょうに
お互いに背を向いているということは
だからこの行儀作法っていうのはコミュニケーションなんです
これが必要ですよ 人間は野生動物ではなく
社会人です わがまま好き勝手には生きていられないんです
行儀作法は 2種類です
だから行儀作法は必要です
人間は野生動物じゃないんだからね
この 2つは何なのかというと
体の行為と言葉 それ難しくないんですよ
行儀作法といえば 体をどのように動かすか
言葉をどのように使うかということだけですよ
で 行儀作法の続き えーと
無意味で役にも立たない迷信により作られた行儀作法は
仏教では認めません だから
行儀作法 行儀作法やと言っても
無意味な行儀作法 無意味な言葉
昨日かな ある人から電話がありまして
何かあの 何か頼みたいんですね
私から それで 何でしょうかというと
もう自己紹介から喋る
自己紹介しなくて この前ももう知ってる人でしょうし
だから何々さんだよと言えばいいでしょうに
私は実は何々者で こういうこういうことをやっている人で
こういうこういうことで
こういうことで この前とはこういう場所で私に会ったことがあります
そこから始めればいいのに
はこの前も聞いたんだから知ってるでしょうに
それでももう十五分ぐらい
私はうん うん それだけ
聞いてないし まあ無駄話やな
この野郎と思いながらね
もうとっくに読まれてるんですよ
何言いたがってるのかと
で ずっとそれでこの手紙があって
翻訳してほしいという話なんですよ
なので私はでは送ってください
私の言葉 あの十五分以上のかかった会話で
それだけ では送ってください
それがえ？わかってないんです
このバカが 何十五分喋ったんですかね
手紙を翻訳してほしいでしょう
だから送ってください
それだけのことでしょうに
だからこれにはもうどうせどんな人間でもかなり
イカれますから 私はそれであのね
手紙を郵便で送ってくださいと声高くして言ったんです
声高くすると大体人間怯えるんです
私の場合は 怒ってないんです
ただ声高くすればそれ十分です
結構怯えて震えるんです
だから私は過去世でライオンでいたか
皆様は過去世で鹿でいたか
どちらかわかりませんだけど
まあそれはどちらでいいんですけど
これで震えちゃって もう喋ることもできなくなっちゃって
もうそういうなんか失礼なこと
まあまあ それでまあはい
わかりました お願いします
またお願いすることに
また十分ぐらい喋りたかったんですけど
まあそれで電話私は切っちゃったんです
勇気あるならば怒るでしょうね
だからいかに人に迷惑かけるかというと
何のことないちっぽけなことですよ
人を助けだから これは翻訳してあげればいいということで
まあ十分ぐらいの仕事で
これにこのバカが私の三十分以上時間取るし
あの嫌な気持ちが体から脱出排除するために
私はまた三十分ぐらいかかるんだから
これで一時間怒るんだから
抗議に どれほど迷惑が連鎖するのかというと
だからただ単にこのもう行儀作法
行儀作法といっても いい加減にしてほしいんですよ
挨拶するんだからといって
この三十分挨拶するんじゃないんですよ
だからまあそういうところは適当に変えてほしいんです
三十分も経っているのに
まだ挨拶しかしていないと
これは日本人同士ではうまくいくんですけど
やっぱり日本というのはもう国際社会になっているんだから
まあいろいろ外国人とも喋ったりすることになるしね
もう携帯しか人生がない人々にとっては
もうこれも三時間喋った方が一番儲かったことになりますからね
でも 忙しい人にとっては
もうこの一時間かかる挨拶っていうのは結構大変きついし
もう仕事をやってくれないということは明らかでしょうね
その場合も だって仕事にかかる時間よりはもう三倍
三倍使ってますからね
電話に頼むために だから行儀作法
行儀作法といっても 仏教はそういう無茶苦茶無意味な役に立たない行儀作法なんかはあまり相手にしない
例えば必ずしも店の前で塩を持ちをするべきかないかとかね
あの塩を持っておくでしょ
それはもうそれなりのすごいかっこいいお皿で
まあ日本和風の店で あのタヌキもいて
いろいろあって まあそこで塩を持っていれば
それは日本文化として美しいかもしれません
だからといって これはフランス料理屋さんの前でも
なんでやるのかと 気持ち悪いでしょうね
だから行儀作法といっても
それなりに考えた方がいいんです
あるいは店によってでっかい皿でもう十キロぐらい塩を持っておいたっても
それかっこよく美しくデザインして置いておけば
決して悪くないんですよ
だから行儀作法の場合はそこら辺考えてほしい
無意味なことはやらない
迷信的なことはまあ時と場合によってやるかやらないかとかね
ただ決まりだからってやるんじゃなくて
これ人間関係だから 人間関係すごくうまくいくために行儀作法を守るということなんです
社会の秩序を保たれる
互いに仲良くなり 親しくなるような行儀作法が大事です
だから行儀作法の決まりはそれだけ
社会の秩序は守る 守られる
保たれる お互いに仲良くなれる
よく親しめられる 例えばお互いに仲良くなれるんだったらね
踊りましょうとかね そこで盆踊りでも阿呆踊りでもやったことで
お互いすごく仲良く仲良くなるんだったら
それ行儀作法ですよ 正しい行儀作法
なぜかって それによってみんな仲良くなったんだから
社会は生きているものなので
行儀作法は減ったり増えたり変わったりするんですよ
社会っていうのは生き物だからね
で 我々の間違うところは
この行儀作法を固定させようとしてるんですよ
これはありえないんです
社会は生き物だから 行儀は減ったり増えたり変わったりします
人はそれに適切に対応する必要があります
だから それに適切に対応して行儀作法を守りましょうと
行儀作法を守ると立派な社会関係を作れます
で 次に性格  4番目 社会の役に立つ能力があっても
性格が悪い人 道徳的でない人は社会性を失っているんですよ
例えば自分にはいっぱい能力ある
人の役に立つといえばものすごい役に立ちますが
性格が悪い そうすると社会は相手にしないんですよ
それで社会関係がうまくいかないんですよ
ただ単に自分に能力がある
私なら人の役に立つと言い張っただけで
人々をお願いします 仲間に入れてあげますということになりません
だから性格も大事なんです
もし性格が悪ければ 明白なセカンドストレスですよ
例えば立派な医者が腕のいい医者がいる
しかし 性格が悪い 誰も行かなくなっちゃいますよ
患者さんに怒鳴るとか
患者さんを馬鹿にするとか
例えば手術しなくちゃ
お前らみたいな馬鹿な生き方をするんだから
頭悪くて だからそんなひどい目に遭いますからとか
迷惑ですけどと言いながら
腕がいいんだからしっかり手術はする
人はしっかり治す それは問題ないんですよ
腕がいいんだから でもそんなことを言う医者のところに行かないでしょ
だから能力があっても役に立っても
性格が悪いとすべてダメになっちゃって
社会関係が壊れるんです
性格は自分と社会をつなぐパイプラインですよ
性格っていうのは 私と社会がつなげるパイプラインです
スムーズな社会関係を築くため
幸福になるため 死後地獄に落ちないためならどう
性格を絶対条件です だから性格っていうのは冗談じゃないんですよ
自分を守るだけで自分も幸せになる
社会とうまくいく それだけじゃない
死後地獄に落ちませんだからね
だから性格っていうのはものすごい大事なことで
守った方がいいんです
5番人権ということです
さて 私は何を今説明したかというと
皆様の宿題なんですけど
社会から学ぶというテーマなんです
社会の中で人間関係をうまく見事にいっている場合
そこで何だろうかと これはと調べてリストアップしてください
その時 そのリストが来るんだよと
皆様はリストアップすると
決してこういう順番では来ないと思いますし
こういう単語も全然出てこないと思いますけど
もうそれでもいいんだから
とにかく細かい細かいリストでも 100項目でもいいんです
リストアップしてください
うまくいっている秘訣をこれリストアップすると
もう 100ぐらい 300ぐらい出てきますよ
それがまとめると これになるだけの話です
これはブッダの知恵でまとめることだからね
これにはかなわないと思いますけど
だから我々は自分たちの能力でリストアップした方がいいんです
5番目 人権ということ
何の躊躇もなく人は他人の人権を侵害する
あなたのために言っているのではないかと開き直って
親が子供の人権を侵害する
わがままで自我自我出張で人権を侵害するでしょう
みんなね とにかく人の人権を侵害する
お母さんもやってます
生命の人権 生きる権利を大事にする人は皆に好かれる
だから人権侵害しない社会ではうまくいきますよ
それだけのこと 簡単でしょ
それでまとめ  5つしかないんです
リストの中で 以上説明した 5つしかありませんので
完全な社会環境を築くことはそれほど難しいことではありません
この 5つを覚えておけば
これぐらいのこともわからないのは理性がないからです
それぐらいもわからないんですからね
人間には理性がないんですよ
主観ばかりで妄想にふけって生きているからです
妄想する人は現実離れです
だから この世間知らずやら何だから言うのは
妄想にふけっている 理性がない
ただそれだけ 妄想にふけっているということは
もう現実離れしていますよ
だからそんなのはやめちゃって
あの 5つの条件を 今日から実行しようと思えば
もう最高な世界が現れてきます